hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be another Suicide Squad video
I know a lot of people are talking about
the Jason Todd Robin you know maybe
that's who the Joker is secretly playing
I'm actually kind of hoping they don't
go there just because I feel like Jason
Todd is the person you roll out when you
really want to stick it to Batman and
Superman is going to be doing that all
over Batman V Superman so like we're
already getting that I also feel like it
kind of takes away from the myth of the
Joker like the Joker can't just be this
really awesome character by himself he
would secretly have to be someone that
Batman fails along the way like what one
of the failed Robins in in the the
narrative of Suicide Squad and Batman V
Superman or mostly Batman V Superman is
that Batman has failed his family
they're already doing that so they don't
need to double down but the story of how
Batman failed you know like
quote-unquote failed depending on how
you look at it Jason Todd and how he
went on to become the Red Hood is is a
really interesting story I mean they
turned into an animated movie it's been
done in the comics for a long long time
there is this shot of Ben Affleck
looking at the Robin costume that's been
graffiti by the Joker arguably after a
death in the family type arc that's why
everyone is wondering like which Robin
it is that the Joker killed the problem
is is that under normal circumstances if
we knew they were adapting any any kind
of comic book arc we would say yeah this
is happening after death in the family
so this is Jason Todd's costume that
we're looking at but Zach Snyder has
been very open about how like they
haven't even gone close to the comics
the closest Batman V Superman is getting
to comic book storylines is like visual
imagery from Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns like this shot right here
so don't automatically assume Jason Todd
red hood is coming down the road but
that is something that they could keep
in their back pocket the other Robin the
people were talking about last year like
when we just had like behind the scenes
leaks and stuff to follow like we barely
had any information about the production
was the Carey Kelly Robin
because Jena Malone is in the movie and
nobody knew what she was doing and
because the movie looked very much like
Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns
people were assuming Carrie Kelly
because she was the Robin of that story
it also doesn't help that Holly Hunter
is a ginger in this movie but I feel
like her character in this movie is is
too old to have been a Robin in a
previous lifetime Robin would always be
younger than Batman in Batman in this
movie is supposed to be in his late 40s
Holly Hunter looks like she's the exact
same age or maybe just like a little bit
older
but let's use this to talk about our
favorite Robbins and when you pull from
all over the comics like all over the
continuity they're in even 12 even
though everybody is totally in love with
Damian Wayne right now because he's he's
an awesome Robin he's a great character
I feel like Dick Grayson is still the
most famous Robin just because he was
Robin for the longest period of time he
started out in Detective Comics number
38 in 1940 it didn't stop being the you
know the Boy Wonder until the early
1970s when he became the teen wonder I
feel like after 30 years you know it's
probably okay to let a character grow up
just like a little bit he really didn't
become Nightwing till the 1980s and then
that was during the Teen Titans phase
but it was like you know they wanted to
transition to a new Robin and they
wanted to give Dick Grayson this
character that had been popular for so
long this new life so giving him this
new persona was probably one of the best
moves they could make you know otherwise
they would they would have had to fridge
him and they hadn't got to the hardcore
point when they were killing Robins off
yet in the continuity just because he's
the oldest of all Robins like he's
worked with Batman the longest he is one
of the first people to take the mantle
of the bat after Bruce Wayne dies or
goes away Bruce Wayne has this list of
people that he feels like are capable of
succeeding him Dick Grayson is really
high if not at the top of that list so
as they were transitioning Dick Grayson
to Teen Titans in the Nightwing persona
they brought in Jason Todd as the new
Robin he appeared for the first time in
Batman 368 and that was in 1983 he
didn't have a very long run as Robin I
feel like you know it wasn't quite as
successful like he didn't quite live up
to the the level that the editors wanted
him to so that's when they did death in
the family Frank Miller and other
artists and writers like him we're
taking the comics in this really
hardcore direction so they let the Joker
kill him he didn't come back as Red Hood
though till Batman 6:35 so that was you
know like many many years later if
you've been playing arkham knight he's
also a big part of that game - i won't
say how but i feel like everybody
already knows he even got to be batman
for a little while or at least you know
call himself batman during battle for
the cowl even though batman does have a
contingency plan for who he wants to
succeed him not everybody agrees with
that so it's kind of like this
Shakespearean tragedy battle for the
cowl was actually a pretty awesome story
the King dies and all the sons fight
over who gets to be King Ned
so the next Robin was Tim Drake he
obviously he came along just as Jason
Todd was going out his first appearance
in the comics just as Tim Drake before
he became Robin though it was Batman 436
he didn't appear as Robin in the comics
until like a couple issues later in
Batman 442 he went on to take the Red
Robin persona then we get to the
Stephanie Brown Robin the first female
Robin technically Carrie Kelly had been
a Robin before that but Frank Miller's
Dark Knight Returns isn't considered
part of the continuity of like the of
the main comics it's like a spin-off
universe she was also known as spoiler
for a brief period she kind of went
through like like a death rebirth type
or just like Jason Todd not quite as
hardcore but still she had a really
tragic past then she went on to become
Batgirl I feel like she has a lot of fun
Batgirl stories I like her more as
Batgirl than I liked her as Robin or
spoiler and then rounding out our main
continuity that the most current Robin
is Damian Wayne who most of you have
probably seen Grant Morrison actually
like pulled him from the ether like way
back in the comics because he appeared
as a baby in the comics as the unnamed
baby of Talia al Ghul and Bruce Wayne
that was back in like 1987 I think it
was Batman's son of the demon grant
morrison was the one that gave him the
Damian Wayne name and like pulled him
into the main continuity and was like
look this is a person he grew up now
he's yours to take care of sort of like
Talia al Ghul is leaving a baby at the
fire station like here you go he's all
yours
enjoy so his first appearance in like in
the main continuity as like like a fully
formed character was Batman number 655
he didn't become Robin though till like
the self-titled Batman and Robin's
storyline that Grant Morrison wrote that
started in 2009 and he has basically
been like the hardcore Robin ever since
but he's gone through a lot of different
iterations they even gave him like a
death and rebirth arc which is actually
really good but that's only five what
about the other seven so first there's
the Carrie Kelly Robin that I talked
about in Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns storyline and then the other six
were all from the same storyline there
was like a group of Robins from a story
called we are Robin that's actually
taking place like this year like as as
we speak so if you're a big fan of Robin
I mean it's an interesting take on the
character the idea behind
producing all these Robins is just to
kind of showcase the diversity of Gotham
City so they're trying to elevate the
myth of Robin
you know while answering the question
why you know Batman would take a child
and put them on the streets put them in
danger like why do these teens feel like
they need to go out and fight crime why
they taking the mantle you guys can kind
of decide whether you like it or not
like the way the way they play with the
Robin mythos I mean some people just
like there being one Robin one Batman
but you know every once in a while I
feel like there's just like there's so
many Batman and Robin comics they have
to mix things up so I do give them bonus
points for trying something different
but we'll see if they stick the landing
right now they've only been two issues
of that series so it's a little too soon
to tell
most of my poll is fried our is like
secret wards and all all the tie ins
Captain America war bound it gives me
such hope for like some acid trip of a
Marvel Jurassic Park crossover like
Jurassic Wars the dark world
just picture Chris Evans with a Raptor
pack riding on the back of a t-rex
that looks mysteriously red like the Red
Skull so here's my big question for you
guys who is your favorite Robin from the
comics and who are you hoping to see in
the movies at a certain point like I
said it seems like the movies it seems
that the paradigm they're going with is
like a post Robin universe like Batman
has failed his family so Robin died the
city's in ruins Gotham City is going to
so you know maybe by the time he
picks himself back up in this Batman
solo film will see another Robin but the
modern film Savoy's flirted with that
idea like Joseph gordon-levitt is as
close as we have gotten to a modern
Robin in the movies I feel like my
favorite Robin right now is just been
Damian Wayne just because they've had a
lot of fun with that character he is as
close as you can get to Deadpool if
Deadpool became a Robin and there's the
promise of the Batman that he will
become someday when Bruce Wayne
eventually dies they eventually they've
done some like some flash forwards in
the comics where you see him wearing a
Batman costume like an adult Damian
Wayne his costume is kind of like a
cross between Rachele ghoul and Batman's
cape and cowl so I think what I'm gonna
do for my next Batman V Superman Suicide
Squad videos it may be something on
Harley Quinn I just I haven't done a
video on her in a long time like the
closest we've gotten to her in the
movies and TV shows so far has been
arrow and since the movies cast her like
that's just totally not going to happen
but I would say of all DC characters she
is like the newest most popular
a female character that they've ever
created and she actually hasn't even
been around for that long a time I feel
like a lot of people that like Harley
Quinn liked her for the same reasons
that they liked Damian Wayne just
because they're kind of like pure it at
certain times like they say the
unsayable they say things to Batman in
the Joker respectively that you just you
can't get away with that norm normal
characters wouldn't be able to do so in
case you haven't seen it I just did a
Gotham trailer video in a history of the
Batcave you can click here to watch that
and that'll also have like the other
videos in my playlist for like the new
seasons of TV like I just did agents of
shield season 3 they're doing secret
warriors you can click here to learn
about what's going on with the flash
right now like they've just started
releasing a whole bunch information
about the new season and arrow too so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
Oh